hello everyone and welcome to this
session
of blockchain tutorial my name is
saurabh and i'm part of the simply learn
team so let's get started and understand
what's in it for us today so let's check
in hypothesis in a city
not so far away somebody was up to
something bad so there is a hacker
who hates the bank who wants to steal
the money
of all the people lying in the bank now
here's why i hate them even more what
are the nuances and the
problem areas of the banking system the
banking system has
higher transactional and international
transfer costs
a lot of documentation is required for
setting up of an account for opening an
account
and onboarding a customer and the
banking system is not always accessible
it's not 24x7
it's closed on banking holidays and it
has other limitations also like transfer
limits in a day
and you know you can't transfer x amount
within a stipulated time
now bank in such a ecosystem acts
as a center point of failure it is a
centralized
based system which is prone to failure
from a centralized point of view so if
the bank fails all the transactions will
come to an halt which are dependent on
the bank now let's see
what happens if the hacker is able to
get into the banking system
and hacks the bank all the investors
or the people associated with the bank
the information associated with them
will get corrupted will get jeopardized
and
it can lead to huge losses to the bank
and to the individuals
and all this can happen with a click of
a button
it's as simple as that so once a hacker
has access to the system he can
manipulate the system
compromise the information share it with
the parties which are not supposed to
have that information
and lot can go wrong though the hackers
can be caught
right it is possible through cyber
security and
various means but once the information
is compromised it is very
difficult to roll that back and that's
why we need more
secure systems and systems which are not
dependent on a centralized authority
which work
in a more decentralized fashion thereby
making it hack proof plus lowering the
transaction cost also
now this incident of course will catch
the bank manager's attention now he
will go to his advisors and want to make
sure
this does not happen again so the
technology com
people the advisors will make sure that
this does not happen but
what is the remedy so the remedy is
setting up a blocked head now
of course the manager who's looking into
the banking functions might not be aware
of the technology
and what benefits blockchain bring onto
the table
in order to prevent such an incident so
that's what we are here for we will
learn
before we go and understand what can
blockchain actually achieve for us
so we will understand today what is
blockchain the bitcoin
story the features of blockchain like
public distributed ledger
the hashing encryption the proof of work
consensus algorithm
and the concept of mining and then we
will cover up a use case
where how blockchain can be used for
banking operations
now what is blockchain blockchain is a
list of records
called blocks which stores data publicly
and in a chronological order and the
entire information
is persisted using cryptography it is
secured using cryptography
so cryptography ensures that the privacy
of the user is maintained
and data cannot be altered information
on a blockchain network is not
controlled by a centralized authority
so unlike modern financial institutions
nobody controls the data within a
blockchain
the data is maintained by the
participants of the network
and they are the democratic authority in
order to approve
any transaction which can happen on a
blockchain network
access to anyone on the network so a
typical blockchain network is a public
blockchain
so as long as you have access to the
network you have access to the data
within the blockchain
if you are a participant on the
blockchain network you
will have the same copy of the ledger
which all other participants have
so therefore everyone every participant
on the network has the same copy of the
data so everyone in the network has a
copy of the blockchain data
which is used for ensuring the data
remains untempered so even if one node
or
data on one particular participant
computer gets corrupted the other
participants will come to know
immediately that this particular
instance or node has gone corrupted and
they will rectify it as soon as possible
so basically
the question is is this the same
technology that bitcoin works on
and the answer is yes bitcoin could not
have been possible without blockchain so
we will understand
how bitcoin adopted blockchain in order
to
reach to its journey today so bitcoin
was introduced
in 2009 by someone or a group of
people known as satoshi nakamoto it
aimed to solve the problem
faced by fiat currencies with the help
of blockchain technology
now as of today in 2018 there are more
than 1600 cryptocurrencies that follow
the concepts of bitcoin and blockchain
for example the other popular
cryptocurrencies are like ethereum
litecoin dash ripple and many more
now let me explain how a bitcoin
transaction works
the sender transmits the transaction
details
worldwide basically whenever a sender
has to do a transaction he has to send
bitcoins to a receiver
he will submit the transaction on the
public blockchain network of bitcoin
and transmit it now verification to
authenticate users
it is done by the miners around the
world so basically there are
specific participants in the bitcoin
network which are called as
miners whose job is to verify the
authenticity of the sender
and the receiver and also validate
whether the sender has the right amount
of balance
for the bitcoin which he is trying to
send to the receiver
and ensuring that the sanity of the
underlying blockchain network to the
bitcoin
remains correct and not get corrupted so
once the miner has authenticated the
transaction
verified all the parameters the
transaction is added to a block
and then that block is made part of the
main blockchain
once the block is added to the
blockchain the money
the transactions which were associated
in the block then gets executed
money is deducted from the sender's
wallet and is added to the
receiver wallet thereby once the
transaction is completed the block is
added
and the ledger across all the nodes are
updated
each and every participant ledger copy
is updated with that particular block
which has been added in the blockchain
so therefore
all the participants have the same copy
of the information
now so what makes blockchain special now
these are the special four features of
blockchain which we're going to talk
about in detail
it is a public distributed ledger it
works
using a hashing encryption each and
every block
has a hash value which is the digital
signature of the block
all the transactions are approved and
verified on the blockchain network
using proof of work consensus algorithm
and
the blockchain network utilizes the
resources
of the miners who are there to validate
the transaction
and the miners in lieu of putting up
investing in the resources and
validating the transactions
get rewards in terms of bitcoin and that
process is called mining
now public distributed ledger let's
imagine four friends
sharing a particular document amongst
each other correct
now if there was only a single copy of
that document
and one of them altered the data it may
go unnoticed
however the outcome would be different
if each one of them
had a copy of the data so therefore if
each and every participant has the same
copy of the data
even if one of them changed the data the
others would find
that the data does not match with their
own so blockchain works in a similar
fashion
the data within a blockchain is
accessible to everyone so with this
as long as you are part of the network
you could access the
entire history of transactions that have
taken place
since the blockchain was created since
inception
and the first block in any blockchain is
called the genesis block so from the
genesis block
to the current block you will have the
access to the entire chain
any additions to blockchain have to be
approved by the participant
users in the blockchain network so a
majority of the members
within the network have to approve of
any additions to the blockchain
this is the public part of the ledger
and this is important because
any additions made to the blockchain are
permanent and are
immutable so immutable transactions are
the transactions which cannot be altered
once registered they cannot be modified
and
are available for audit and verification
24x7
so this means that each and every detail
is recorded and
any alterations can be detected by
verifying it against
everyone's personal version of the
blockchain so if someone's tried to
modify a data on a block on a particular
node
then the other ledgers which are having
the same information
will come to know that someone has
modified data on one particular node and
they will try to rectify
and the fourth property no central
authority
is controlling the working of this
blockchain network it is a decentralized
network
so this is where being decentralized
helps everyone has a copy of the
blockchain which means there is no
central point of failure
there is a single source of truth even
if things go wrong the data can be
recovered if one node goes wrong the
data can be recovered
from other nodes but what about security
how is privacy maintained if
everything is so public and here hashing
encryptions
comes into picture it takes care of that
now we will talk about the second
feature which is
hashing encryption but to understand
hashing encryption
we need to understand the contents what
are the contents of a block
so a block in a blockchain is like a
container that
holds aggregated transactions it
contains certain set of transactions
so we will see what all things construct
a particular block
so a block has two parts it has a header
and it has the second part is the
transaction details
it is the set of transactions which are
aggregated in this block
now the header has following set of
attributes
it has the block version number it has
the
hash of the previous block to which it
is linked the current timestamp the
timestamp at which the block was
verified
the nonce nonce we will see what is the
attribute
what is the meaning of nonce and target
value now the transaction details are
nothing but
the example which we talked about
earlier it is the transaction which the
sender and receiver are sharing
the sender is trying to send certain
amount of bitcoin from his account to
the receiver's account now it is
represented
in the form of a 256 bit hash value in
the header called as
merkle root or the hash root so
basically
the merkle root is the hash of all the
transactions
structured in a merkle tree called
binary tree it's a kind of a binary tree
and the hash value of the root node of
the merkle tree
is called the merkle root hash so the
transaction details of a block
are contained in the header in a hex
value known as
merkle root the merkle root can be
calculated in this way so basically
the list of transaction each transaction
is passed through a hashing algorithm
then all the hashes of the transactions
are paired and then again passed through
another hashing algorithm
until only one value remains and which
will be
the root now let me tell you how a hash
function works
blockchain utilizes a hash function to
perform
cryptography data from a data set of
random size is sent as input to a
hashing function
to get an encrypted value of fixed size
and that is the feature of any hashing
function so some unique properties
of hashing function are these are
deterministic
the same input will always produce the
same hash
output small changes in the data can
drastically change the output so
basically
any small change to the input produces
an output that's drastically different
from its previous obtained
outputs it can be computed easily the
output values can be obtained without a
whole lot of calculation
and hashing functions are one-way
functions basically you won't be able to
determine the input
based on the output value so you can't
do the reverse calculation
now let's go back to our block we were
talking about earlier
so as we were discussing what are the
features in the header
the previous hash is the resultant hash
of the previous block in the blockchain
and this is the way two blocks are
linked together now transaction details
these are used to provide details about
the sender
receiver and how much money they want to
exchange between them
and this is a list of transactions and
they are structured in a merkle tree and
the hash of the merkel
root is put in the header nonce is a
value
that is varied to create a unique hash
address of the block which should be
less than the target hash value so this
is the structure of the header it has a
block
version number basically the sequence
number of the block it has the hash
of the previous block the timestamp when
the block was mined and verified
the nonce value the header is then this
entire header
is then passed through a hashing
algorithm in the case of a bitcoin
network it is sha-256
and a hash value is generated and now
this hash value
becomes the hash value of the block now
this value is a 256 bit value
that is used to uniquely identify the
particular block
so sh 256 ensures that
alterations to data can be easily
detected
so for example consider these two blocks
in the blockchain they have a similar
structure
and definitely different hash values now
if someone alters the transaction
details
in the first block the corresponding
hash value of the block
would change too now the values of hash
value
of the first block and the previous hash
value of the other block will not match
basically the block subsequent to the
hacked block will get d-linked now this
will raise an alarm
among the users informing them that data
alteration has taken place
the users will then be able to flag the
block
so the alteration can be easily
identified and
rectified immediately to ensure security
blockchains also include digital
signatures
these ensure that the message come from
the right
identity right person and that the
message
is not tampered with users are provided
their own
private and public key so whenever a
user onboard a public blockchain
he is provided a pair of public and
private key now private key
is used by the user to control his her
own account this is kept as a secret by
the user so basically it
is like his own password and public key
public key is used to identify the user
on the network
this is shared by the user along with
the transaction
on the network for others to verify so
these are the steps involved in creating
and authenticating a digital signature
so at the sender side
the message to be transmitted is passed
through the hashing algorithm
in in this case of bitcoin it is she-256
and the hash is generated
plus the private key is used to generate
a digital signature now this
output is passed through a signature
algorithm
along with the user's private key to
create a digital signature now during
the transmission
the user's message their digital
fingerprint which was generated in the
previous step plus the public key are
transmitted across the network so these
three things
are published on the network for the
validators for the miners to use and
verify the
authenticity of the sender now at the
receiver's end first the message
is passed through a hashing algorithm
now at the same time
the sender's public key and his or her
digital signature are passed through a
very fiction algorithm
now both the functions will generate a
hash if
both the hashes are compared and if they
match
then the transaction and the identity of
the sender
is approved otherwise it is rejected so
basically this is the process
by comparing the hash values to
authenticate the identity of the
sender now what about the people who
verify these transactions
and how do they actually do it so
remember that one field in the block
header called
norms that becomes very important in
order to verify the transaction
so now we will talk about the third
feature which is the proof of work
consensus algorithm so proof of work
involves
people around the world the participants
in the network
called miners competing to be the first
one
to add a block to the blockchain and in
lieu of this
they will be rewarded there are
competing miners around the world
they are trying to solve a mathematical
puzzle to be the first one
to be rewarded and to add a block to the
blockchain so
this is the reward so thereby they
invest in the computing power
they invest in the resources in order to
mine
and validate a transaction to get that
reward now
what is the mathematical puzzle so
basically they need to find a hash value
that satisfies certain predefined
conditions
now in order to find the hash value they
will use
norms so this target hash value is
decided
months in advance for every block the
miners
keep variating the nonce value to find
out an
output that falls within the target
requirement so they keep on generating a
hash value
using the norms and if it is less than
the target the hash value is accepted
and if it is greater than the hash value
is rejected
the minus effort is not considered valid
now a minor transmits across the world
that he has found a nonce that
satisfies the target requirement as soon
as you find it and thanks to the hashing
algorithm used
this claim can be easily verified by
others so basically
the proof of work algorithm it is very
hard
to generate the nonce and get the hash
value but it is very easy to verify the
transaction
by the other miners so that's a whole
lot of work what a miner's payoff is
so for all his or her hard work they get
paid
in the bitcoins and this is the only way
the bitcoins get added to the network
sometimes they get other forms of
remuneration as well
and this is the concept of mining so the
entire process
when the miner has done the proof of
work consensus
they are rewarded and this is called as
mining so mining is the process
of adding a block to the blockchain this
miner
is the first person who found a nonce
value
that fell within the target requirement
right now for doing this
the miner is rewarded as of today on the
bitcoin network a miners pay 12.5
bitcoins
for adding a block onto the blockchain
but
the reward a miner gets reduced by
half every four years so when the fourth
year will approach
for the threshold the bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 bitcoins
and miners also get the sum of all the
transaction fees for that particular
block
so the 12.5 bitcoin reward is justified
as mining is a very expensive process
it has a heavy toll on electricity
computing power
and other resources on which the miner
has invested
now we will take a look at the use cases
where blockchain is applicable in banks
so we have been incorporating a program
where banks can validate
user identity as of now a user
needs to do the process over and over
again in each bank
he has to go and prove the identity in
each bank
is there a way we can ease the process
with blockchain
and the answer is yes we can we will be
using
truffle ethereum ganache and smart
contracts
all of these blockchain technology
ecosystem to make it work
and welcome to this demo for how to
build your kyc
blockchain application now i'm gonna
show you all the steps
required to deploy your kyc application
what all components are to be developed
and how to go about deploying and
testing your application
so primarily this kyc application will
allow banks to do a decentralized kyc of
the customers which come to
their banks so in the demo we will see
when a customer
walks into the initiating bank will do
the kyc for a customer
enter its details and verify it and if
any subsequent bank
wants to use the kyc done by another
bank
he or she needs to take the permission
of the customer
and then he can use the same kyc for
verification so we will see
how can we do that so just to start off
with we have developed
a kyc solidity contract
which has all the necessary functions in
order
to do the actions required for
doing a kyc of a particular entity by
the bank now once
this contract is ready we will be
placing it in our
sample truffle package so this is my
truffle package
and in this i have the contracts folder
in the contracts folder i have kept my
kyc dot solve file now in the
command prompt i will
compile my contracts
we can ignore the warnings
so here is my ganache client which i
have just started and in my ganache
client
as you can see it is running on port
8545
and it has already given me 10 accounts
pre-funded with
100 ether now i had already mentioned
that my truffle is connected to
localhost 8545
so now when i'll do my truffle
migrate command it will connect to my
ganache
and deploy my kyc contract
so now i can go to trifle control and
for me it's very important to
see at which particular address my
solidity contract has been deployed i'll
copy it
and in my ui code
under root jscontractdetails.js
i will make the change of this address
where my contract has now been deployed
now
after doing these steps my application
is ready
to interact with my solidity contract
which is being deployed
on my local blockchain network now as
you can see when i deployed the contract
this is my primary account from which
the ethers were deducted
in order to deploy the contract now
there are certain steps in order to
get the application up and running so
first
we need to sign up the banks
so suppose i say bank one and the
password should be
the first address of the bank so
basically we are associating one bank
with one account which we have
on our ethereum network so we will sign
up now bank one
is successfully registered so our i now
in order to
log in i can check
now bank one i have logged in now i need
to do
add a kyc for a particular customer
now after filling the basic details i
will create
the customer and the username i have
kept is customer1
ideally this is the unique identity of
the customer it can be any social
security number or the idhaar number or
any
unique identity which is attached to the
customer or the email id
and can be used as the unique identifier
for the customer
now once customer profile is
successfully created
we need to login as a customer to allow
this bank to see the kyc details now
suppose
if i say customer1 and search it it is
saying access denied and take the
permission from customer to proceed
so before the bank can do the
kyc complete the customer need to
approve it so i am creating the
credentials for the customer
now customer can see his details
whatever were
filled by bank one and he can see
that there is a request from bank one to
allow to view his kyc now
before we allow i will also create
another bank
bank 2 and associate it with my
another address
and try to log in with it
now bank 2 is also logged in now bank 2
has not
done the original kyc right but it is
trying to look up
and it access is also denied so it needs
to explicitly take permission
so the bank will take explicit
requests from the customer so now
the customer has requests from bank one
and bank 2 for the kyc it is up to the
customer
whether he or she wants to allow and
deny
the kyc request after the permission has
been granted
then only the banks can be able to view
the
kyc so if i say bank one allow
and bank to deny
now all the requests are done from the
queue so bank one was allowed and bank
two was denied
so if i again log in with
bank 1 and the password is my
first address view kyc customer1
so here it is the bank 1 is able to see
the details
now if i log in as bank
2 and give password and try to see the
it is saying permission denied so let's
ask
bank 2 to again request
now bank 2 is now again a question and
now this time
it allows
now bank 2 can see the details so all
these transactions in the back end
are happening on the blockchain network
which is interfacing with the contract
through its subsequent methods
now the primary details of the contract
are in the contract details.javascript
where
we have to provide the address at which
the contract was deployed
the abi file the api so you can get the
api
at here this is the avi and you can
paste it here
and this is the binary data
which has to be pasted over here
so the binary data can be fetched
from remix
this is the binary data for the contract
it has to be copied
and pasted over here
now with these essential inputs provided
our application allows us to
interact in a decentralized fashion to
access
the kyc records of a particular customer
now we can modify the details
also and
we can add a new customer again so this
is a basic
demo of how a typical kyc application
works in a banking environment now
before a block can be mined
a miner has to make a very important
decision which
transactions would be added to his block
so before transactions are added to the
blockchain they are collected in a
temporary container
called a memory pool the miners select
transactions
from the school and they put it in a
temporary block
called candidate block so basically the
candidate block is a temporary block
which a minor hopes to add to a
blockchain it's a candidate to be added
to a blockchain so the candidate block
holds transactions that the miner
selects from the memory pool
the miner then tries to be the first
person to
find the nonce value that satisfy the
hash requirements
now the question comes if someone in a
blockchain wanted to input the wrong
data
by spreading wrong information around
would he or she
be able to get away with it and that's
why
we had something known as byzantine
fault tolerance
so in order to maintain the sanity of
the network and to have
the correct consensus there was
something called as byzantine fault
tolerance consensus algorithm to
understand this
you need to know what the byzantine
general's problem is so let's imagine
a byzantine general and three other
lieutenants
need to take over this town however they
are
at different places and can't directly
communicate with each other
so here we have the general and his
three lieutenants
the general has to ensure that all
lieutenants
follow the same order he or she gives
them
to attack or to retreat now this has to
be ensured
even if one of the lieutenants is a
traitor so this
is the byzantine general's problem that
how does the general communicates
the correct decision which he has taken
to all his lieutenants
in his network irrespective if someone
is a traitor in this case
a traitor could ruin the unity of the
group by sending different messages
to different lieutenants now here we can
see that general is giving all his
leftings
the command to attack the traitor could
ruin this
by sending every other left-handed the
command to retreat the opposite
now in this suspicion the traitor would
make others
believe that the general asks them to
retreat
so as we can see the lieutenant in brown
is the traitor
and he could communicate to other
lieutenants the wrong
information and make them act on his
behalf
as a traitor in themselves now this
would cause the lieutenants to retreat
and the generals attack to fail so how
do we tackle this
the only way an attack or a retreat will
be successful
is by having a majority supporting that
particular action
to achieve this the lieutenants keep a
tally of the orders they receive
so in this scenario the general sends
the attack order to
each of his lieutenants the lieutenants
in turn
collect the order they receive and pass
it on to the left in end
near to them so each left hand will pass
this order
to the nearest left in it the traitor
also will do the same
but since the retreat order to the other
left lanes
however this will not be successful
because
each lieutenant now has a majority
of attack and minority of retreat
so this shows that the majority of the
left lanes would follow the general's
command
and the attack will be successful the
scenario
i mentioned before is byzantine fault
tolerance now the same situation can be
encountered in blockchain as well
the traitor would add invalid
transactions into the blockchain
the traitor would send the inconsistent
information to other nodes in a
blockchain
this would affect the reliability of
blockchain
network blockchain are able to achieve
byzantine
fault tolerance with the help of proof
of work let's see
how it is effective it is effective
because the process
of adding a block to a blockchain is a
work
intensive process which involves a
hashing algorithm the process
is very hard very computative because it
is heavily reliant on
value obtained from the existing
blockchain
to have any meaningful impact the hacker
would have to take a lot of time
resources producing sufficient proof of
work
interesting imagine if you and i were
miners
and we both add a block to the
blockchain at the same time
how do we handle the situation so
although
this does not happen very often there is
a way to decide
whose block should be added to the
blockchain in an ideal scenario
you just need to be the first one to
find the hash value
you need to be the first miner to
generate that hash value
and win the block so adding two blocks
at the same time
the hash value of the block only needs
to be
within the predetermined limit if the
generated hash value
is less than the target then the value
is accepted and the block is added to
the blockchain
but if it is greater than the target
then the value
is denied and the block is not added to
the blockchain
but in this case if two people have
obtained a satisfactory
hash value at the same time so minor one
and minor two
were able to find the hash which was
less than the target
then what will happen whether minus one
block will get added to the blockchain
or minus two block will get added to the
blockchain now
fifty percent of the network has
accepted minus one block
and suppose rest has accepted minus two
blocks so half of the network
continues to work considering miners
one block to be the right block and the
other half network continues to work
considering minus two block to be the
right block however
only one minus blockchain can be allowed
to remain
we cannot have two blockchains running
it will defeat the purpose
now this is achieved by selecting the
sub plane to which
miners have first added a block so
suppose
miner 3 adds a new block to miners 1
blockchain
this block now added by miner 3 is
verified by
everyone in the network it is then
accepted as the dominant blockchain
and is used by everyone else in the
network
the other version of the blockchain the
miner 2 is completely discarded
and the entire network now accepts miner
one's blockchain and we have now a
single blockchain
existing now this suspicion is also
called
an accidental fork so i heard about a
version of bitcoin
called bitcoin cash what's the
difference between them
there are other kinds too like bitcoin
gold and bitcoin private
these are all outcomes of a fork so what
is a fork
a fork is said to have taken place when
a blockchain
diverges into two potential parts a fork
happens
when the users of a network cannot come
to an agreement
with regards to a network's transaction
details
and the new rules to validate those
transactions
so there are two types of forks which
can exist either it can be a soft work
or it can be a hard fork a soft fork
occurs when a change
in the soft protocol makes new blocks
added to the blockchain following the
new rules but are backward compatible
but in order to have a soft work it
requires a majority of the users to
commit
to that change to be successful so a
soft fork
could have multiple uses it could be for
tighter rules it could be for cosmetic
changes
addition of new functions but not
affecting the structure
so consider the scenario where the
accepted block size is to be reduced
from 1 mb to 100 kb so first of all
it has to be approved by a majority of
the network
now the old version will be running on
1mb block
size but once approved the new version
will start working on a block size of
100 kb
so anything which is less than 100 kb
will be approved and will be added to
the new block
so over time people following the older
version of the blockchain
would be forced to move to the new one
since none of their transactions would
go through so basically people using the
old blockchain they will be using the
1mb
block size their transactions will not
succeed and they will be forced to use
the 100kb block now let's talk about
hard fork
a hard fork involves a change in the
software protocol
so radical that it forces a new
blockchain to be created altogether so
basically
in a hard fork there will be two
versions there will be one blockchain
that hasn't upgraded
and there will be a blockchain that has
upgraded according to the new software
protocols
both these blockchains will be
considered valid and legitimate
the new path would follow new updated
rules while the other one keeps
following the old path so the old one
will not be discarded and will
remain into existence now bitcoin
performed a hard fork
on first august 2017 which created
bitcoin cash
so thereby both bitcoin and bitcoin cash
remain existent now bitcoin cash was
different
from regular bitcoin because it
increased the block size
from 1 mb to 8 mb so thereby it
helped reducing the transaction cost
significantly lesser
than that of the original bitcoin
network now other than
with bitcoin where else is blockchain
used
the other areas are for preventing voter
fraud blockchain helps
in ensuring that there is only one vote
per person
ensuring that the data is not being
tampered with
or any false alterations are done it
helps creating
an immutable ledger to record the votes
as tallied so once a transaction or a
vote is recorded it cannot be
modified it is also used in quality
assurance
ensuring the products are of highest
quality being able to identify
problem areas easily so where do you
think blockchain is
going to be used in the future so
blockchain is seeing
wide range of adoption amongst
organizations
as of now only one percent of all
organizations have begun using
blockchain technologies
but this percentage is expected to
increase in the next five years or so
then there is a need for blockchain
regulations
the rules and regulations surrounding
blockchain are not very clear
for organizations to be comfortable
using it and
move towards faster adoption also
there's a need for removing this
negative speculations surrounding
blockchain several industries fear that
blockchain will disrupt their normal
functioning
and believe that the adoption of a
blockchain system isn't worth the effort
and there is an increase in job
opportunities for skilled personnel
so as the technology is maturing there
would be a huge requirement for
individuals
who can understand and implement the
concepts of blockchain
so what options do people have for jobs
involving blockchain
at the moment there are many job
opportunities but the two most famous
ones are blocked in architect
and blockchain developer blockchain
developer is a profile
which requires designing implementing
and supporting a distributed
blockchain network analyze user
requirements
design technology around a certain
business model to build
and launch a blockchain network
blockchain architect profile
requires to design an architect
blockchain industry solutions
creates blockchain networks leveraging
blockchain technology platforms
produce high quality code based on
project requirements
conceptualize design and build
blockchain frameworks
and assets so let's have a quick demo
on how to deploy a rating smart contract
and have decentralized application
running on a local
blockchain network we will be using
truffle and
solidity to build this application so in
order to build this application
we should have installed truffle and
ganache on our local system so this is a
ganache client which is running on my
local host
it is running on port 8545 and network
id
5778 whenever you run a ganache client
it is preceded with 10 accounts and 100
ether balance now this is my movie
rating app
and in this app i am going to deploy a
smart contract
called rating.soul which is gonna
capture
the ratings for a certain set of movies
which i'll predefine and the users will
be able to set the ratings on a
blockchain network in a decentralized
fashion
and we will be able to see that in every
transaction
a block is getting generated in my
ganache client so in my
movie rating app under the rating folder
i will run the command
trough compile and it will compile
my smart contract rating dot soul
now the next command which i have to run
is trough
migrate now at this instance
the trough migrate command will deploy
my smart contract on my ganache client
so if you see
there are four blocks which have been
created
and my contract
was created in this transaction and this
is the address
of the contract at which my contract is
deployed so i can go back to my command
prompt and say truff console
and check the address of my contract
so this is 0x695 which is this address
now when i deployed my smart contract i
had given the entry of deployment
in a file called deploy contract.js
under rating migrations
and in that i had given this entry i had
given
the path to my rating solidity file and
i had initialized my smart contract with
three movies star wars
avatar and inception and given some
predefined gas
now once these steps are done and i know
the address at which my contract is
deployed
i will copy that
and paste it in the file
of ethereum setup.js which is lying
under my rating app ui
source folder and i'll just change this
address now once this rating address is
changed i have to go back to my movie
rating app folder
under app ui i have to give the command
npm start
now my application is up and running
on localhost 3000 and as you see
i'm able to do the voting and at each
rating level my block is going to
increase block
6 inception block 7 and as and when my
rating is increasing a block is getting
added
so this demonstrates the usage of
truffle and ganache in order to build
your decentralized app
i hope you all had a great session and
i'll meet you
in my next session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and
click here to watch similar videos turn
it up and get certified
click here